الجنين الحامل بين الواقع والوهم
من تونسيه تلد طفلا يحمل طفلا اخر في بطنه
خبر تداولته كثير من وسائل الاعلام وحاله
نادره تحدث لاول مره في تونس البعض وصفوا
الحاله بالجنين الحامل فما هي حقيقه هذه
الظاهره وكيف يمكن حدوثها الحاله تعرف
طبيا بظاهره جنين داخل جنين وليس الجنين
الحامل تحدث بنسبه حاله واحده بين كل 500
الف ولاده حيه على مستوى العالم ومن اشهر
النظريات المفسره لها ما يعرف بالتوام
الطفيلي فاحد التوامين يبدا بالتشكل جنينا
بشكل طبيعي لكنه يصبح مغلفا داخل توامه
فيتسبب ذلك بمفارقته للحياه لعدم اكتمال
نموه في حاله الام التونسيه اعتقد الاطباء
بالاشهر الاولى من الحمل ان الجنين يحمل
كيسا لكن ومع مرور الاسابيع اظهرت الصور
عمود فقري وعظام ساق في بطن الجنين
ليتاكدوا من انه كان يحمل شقيقه التوام
داخل بطنه تمت الولاده في الثلاثين من
كانون الثاني يناير من عام 2023 في مصحه
خاصه وبعد ايام خضع الجنين لعمليه جراحيه
ليست خطيره لاستئصال شقيقه المتوفى من
داخل بطنه
[موسيقى]